yes we are good morning everybody before
we get started can we all rise for the
pledge
thank you everybody
so being 9 37 welcome to Transportation
I'm going to open up the public hearing
on House Bill 268 FN relative to the
Furnishing of special number plates to
The Liquor Commission division of
enforcement and Licensing uh
representative trottier the prime
sponsor did contact me and I guess it's
representative Coker
thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee uh so this bill um I'm
presenting this for uh representative
trottier uh it's basically a
housekeeping Bill The Liquor Commission
like to get their uh own um plates for
their vehicles just like the state
police and other state departments so uh
this bill will do that so that's about
all I got on it um they're here to
testify on their behalf so I'm not going
to answer any questions
um
I know the lines are small and I'm
having a hard time with the this one the
chair recognizes and supported the bill
looking for five minutes Chief mark
armagedian
all right uh representing the Hampshire
Liquor Commission enforcement
good morning
good morning Mr chairman and thank you
uh in honorable committee members uh
good morning my name is Mark armaganian
um I am the chief and director of the
division of enforcement licensing for
the New Hampshire Liquor Commission
just to give you some background the New
Hampshire Liquor Commission has its own
Police Department that is a regulatory
Police Department unlike traditional
we regulate alcohol and we regulate
tobacco
with that in mind given the uh the
reasoning for this played as as how we
call it a cleanup
my background I came from State Police
28 years with the state police I ran the
Bureau of Investigative Services prior
to that
the Cruisers that I had under my command
had two license plates they had one to
do surveillance and they had another one
to be high profile and transparent The
Liquor Commission doesn't have that
infrastructure and set up
as I was bringing this up over the last
six years that I've been in place
everybody has asked why isn't this
um I don't have a reason for it uh but
under our new Administration we were
brought in to clean up and change a lot
of stuff that uh we felt could be done
better uh and this was one of the many
items that we have changed or are asking
to be changed uh with that in mind our
investigators on a nightly basis are out
at our 6400 licensed establishments
um at times they are running
surveillance so they do need an
undescript license plate or a license
plate that is a regular one
to do some of their daily operations at
the same time we run
um
uh operations or security details at
either open venue
[Music]
establishments like Meadowbrook or New
Hampshire
Bank of New Hampshire Pavilion now
um Bike Week
down at the beach where we have uh
detailing that's magnetic for the cars
we just don't have license plates to be
high profile that license plate I do
have a rendition uh the proposed
rendition or the proposed license plate
will look very similar uh to one when I
rebranded Marine Patrol when they when
they merged into the state police it's
the same blue uh with the white
background we felt it was a good
identifier very easily identified by the
public and by our licensees
um and I've heard no uh negative
pushback on this proposed uh initiative
I can answer any of your questions
thank you very much any questions from
the committee
representative C
about how many uh uh license plates
would be issued under this
uh we have uh right now 30 investigators
uh we have uh three vehicles that are
um multi-use vehicles that would be
plated under under this initiative
um I as I was talking to the director
and and other Personnel uh Mr oberdank
also
um it was uh proposed that we would
probably purchase a dual set just in
case something happened to that first
one uh but we're talking in the area of
maybe
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
next up chair recognizes director of
Motor Vehicles
well actually two people are
representing the Department of Motor
Vehicles director marasco and Jeff
hobedank and both in support of the bill
looking for two minutes
so much and members of the committee
thank you for having me and Jeff here
um as uh director armagedian stated uh
we we do support the bill there's no
fiscal impact to the DMV
um director armagedian originally
reached out to see if that was something
the DMV could do and we realized that
there had to be a change to the statute
it makes sense from a law enforcement
standpoint visibility transparency
um and uh again because there's no no
real impact to our operation we're happy
to do it so we support it registration
supervisor Jeff oberdank can take any
additional questions you may have
me as well
thank you sir questions from the
committee
representative Sinclair
I have to have a question for you guys
to justify my being here I just my
question is why do things like this take
I guess I could start with that I think
this particular statute I give director
armagedy a ton of credit because he
wanted to do the right thing for his
officers and when you look at it and you
realize other agencies are authorized to
have a plate like that but liquor
enforcement wasn't we just wanted to
make that right so this was the Forum to
do it and we're just thankful you're
representative sakes
thank you Mr chairman director uh
perhaps this is for
um
your cohort
we've heard in the past about license
plate bills that have come before us
that there's a significant software cost
involved and I I assume that the as you
just testified your numbers are correct
but can you
sort of explain to me why we don't have
that software issue
uh and creating these plates
so I maybe I can just start with that as
far as uh the the plates will be paid
for by liquor enforcement so from that
standpoint there's no fiscal impact to
the DMV
um aluminum obviously is uh you know
always at a premium but uh but the
number of places we're talking about
here a small number but anything you
have I would also add from a system
standpoint representative that uh we
already have a transaction built for
Municipal Police plates
this would just be using that same
transaction
so we have full audit capabilities to
ensure that we're issuing plates onto
the right transaction type and they're
being charged the right fees thank you
Mr oberdank I appreciate it you're
welcome very good question
representative Sykes thank you for that
uh representative sellers
so when the statute doesn't talk about
design at all except for the motto Live
Free or Die on the plate and I know the
other person that was just up and talked
it had somewhat of a design of the plate
do you have any problems with that at
all or is that more
design come to the DMVs purview as far
as how it's going to be
I think I can start I think the uh the
design of the plate actually models
um other plates that already exist to
include a state police plate uh Marine
Patrol plate and actually I believe uh
the director that's what he
um this plate was actually modeled after
a Marine Patrol plate so they're very
similar
follow-up
so it will still have the Live Free or
Die on there as well right we can
certainly pass this around if you'd like
to take a look at it representative no
I'm all set I just it does say have
lymph Frieda at the top
um it is very recognizable as state
enforcement agency as a liquor state
liquor enforcement and New Hampshire
Liquor Commission so in the event that a
citizen wants to know
um who the vehicle belongs to
um it's clearly identifiable and Live
further questions from the committee
seeing none well with these plates now
you'll be subject to the next bill we
see to remove the private plates so
we'll see how that goes in the future
wish nobody else signed up to speak on
House Bill 268 have been I'm going to
close the public hearing
our next hearing is on Bill
HB
163fn at 10 o'clock
welcome back everybody being
I'm going to open up the public hearing
on House Bill 163 FN relative to
authorized license plate decals uh chair
recognizes the prime sponsor
representative sellers
good morning Mr chair and
representatives thank you for this time
my name is representative sellers I
um at this time this bill here was uh
presented to me uh so I would actually
be a sponsor of it and as a veteran
myself of a little over six years I
looked at this and I said well to me it
just looked like a little bit of
housekeeping
um and to point out a few items here
because there are a couple other
speakers today that will actually
dive into the more details of this as
well but I mean housekeeping you can see
on line 10 you know we've added space
for us
uh which has been new in the last I
think three years or so
and then also on line 16 the Coast Guard
cross
and then you go through a 21 through I
don't know 30 31 I guess
and these are all uh distinguished
metals and also Metals for heroism
and then on the second page one through
four
the speakers behind me um we got the
agent General here today and he's gonna
basically talk to the sections uh 21 to
30 or 21 to 29
um
these seem to be metals that are very
very very seldom given but having them
in the law could mean that even if one
person laundered them and it could be in
the next 20 years it would be uh
what what I understand might be quite a
bit I mean these these these uh Metals
here are basically for kernels and
Generals and so forth on up so they're
not giving out quite that often so
uh other than that there's really not
much more I can say to this you did get
a handout on 163
um
where the veterans plate decals what
they these are the actual decals and
again we have another speaker that will
actually speak to these decals and stuff
so I'll be glad to take any questions at
this time
thank you representative any questions
from the committee representative Jones
thank you um
one of the people that are speaking to
this so are they going to be able to
what do you mean by authentication well
I assume you go to DMV and you have to
show proof that you are
that you meet some of these standards
what I'm hearing in the background yes
they will okay thank you
what are the questions from the
committee
seeing then thank you very much
um
uh next up chair we're recognized is
Warren Perry uh in support of the bill
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
Warren Perry I'm the deputy Edge and
general for New Hampshire's Department
of military Affairs and Veterans
Services we support the bill but we are
going to recommend an amendment to
delete lines 21 through 29 that covers
the distinguished service medals and
I'll talk a little bit about that as we
as we go through uh
for your information the department of
military Affairs and Veterans Services
specifically the division of veteran
services is responsible for the issue
and the authentication of eligibility
for these uh for these decals that go on
to the plates
we believe that the metals in that are
listed in lines 21 through 29 the
distinguished service medals and then
the distinguished service medals for
each of the separate branches including
the defense Superior service medal and
the Legion of Merit are not really
metals that would warrant being put on
decals I mean these are service Metals
they're generally presented to people
who have worked at the highest levels of
the Pentagon or in combatant commands
generally reserved for three and four
star generals or Admirals and very very
rarely uh presented so we just don't
think that they should be on the on the
decal plates right we prefer the metals
that are awarded for Valor or heroism
so we're making the recommendation that
they that they be uh
be deleted from the this particular bill
just for your information we've issued
about
we've you know the issue of the metals
we currently uh issue we've issued only
three sets of Silver Star
only 17 sets of the Bronze Star for
Valor because it requires the valorous
citation and 17 cents for 17 sets of
medals for gold star families and in
each of these cases some veterans who
earned these medals are awarded these
medals bought multiple sets because they
have multiple cars so it's very rare
that we issue Metals metal sets anyway
in terms of the service decals and
adding space force so far we've issued
225 sets of army 122 sets of Navy 152
sets of Air Force
281 sets of Marine Corps Semper Fi
although I was in the Army uh they're
leading the way and 61 sets of the Coast
Guard uh we love we love them all
so from from that perspective we just
think that there won't be any demand for
these particular distinguished service
medals based on the the level you have
to obtain and rank and service to be
able to get them you know I think I know
of one retired three-star General that
lives in New Hampshire his name is Pete
van gel I think he's from Boston some of
you may know him uh used to be my boss
and then uh so we just don't think that
these message you know it's just not
necessary for two reasons one there will
be no demand and two the service medals
are not necessarily presented for Heroic
acts so that's really my statement I'll
uh before I end my statement I'll say
that other the other metals that are
added in this legislation the medals for
heroism that begin on page third line 30
of page two and go through uh line four
of
uh page three those uh those soldiers
metal airmen's metal Navy Marine Corps
metal Coast Guard metal those are metals
that are presented in peacetime for
members of the Department of Defense who
say who risk their lives to save a life
and very very rarely presented right now
I I you know in 28 years of my service
I've only known two people that received
the soldiers medal one of them is one of
our state troopers sethgar who was
pulling people out of The Towers in New
York City on 9 11. so it's a you know
those they deserve to have the sticker
if they want one there's no doubt about
that so we we absolutely support the
other the bill and the other changes we
just recommend that these Metals be
deleted so subject to your questions and
I'm happy to answer all of your
questions
thank you very much questions from the
committee
representative Crawford thank you Mr
chairman could you just give me
yours again for Navy I will I will
absolutely just bring you the paper is
that is that sufficient perfect thank
you so much
further questions from the committee
uh next up chair recognizes Kevin Grady
State veterans advisory committee
doesn't look like taking a position on
welcome thank you Mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen of the committee for the
record my name is Kevin Grady I'm a
25-year veteran of our air force and a
23-year resident of the town of Hooksett
and today I'm here representing the
state veterans advisory committee for
those of you unfamiliar with uh our work
and I'm glad I get a chance to see you
this morning we are a group of 20
veteran service organizations which
should be familiar to your youth things
like the American Legion the veterans of
foreign war Disabled American Veterans I
personally represent the the air and
space forces Association used to be the
Air Force Association now we've added
the space force because they're a
separate service that just celebrated
their third year anniversary in December
um we are chartered actually by state
RSA 115 colon a-8 if you want to look up
what who it is we are and what we do to
sort of speak for the the veterans in
our state one of the things that I do
when we get the language on bills is I
pick out the ones that have better
impact and then I come and I Tell You
Folks what it is that we think about
those bills the reason I haven't taken a
position on this one is pretty much what
Colonel Perry just talked to you about
is that that one section about about the
uh the the awards that are primarily
awards for higher uh uh folks in the in
the military and also are used for
retirements or or permanent change of
station Awards things I will give you an
example when we discuss this at our
state veterans advisory committee
meeting and we did have the language we
voted to follow this rather than take a
position on it because there are parts
we support but then there are other
parts that we think I don't think
there's going to be a lot of demand for
this so the Legion of Meredith typically
award an award you'll see that on line
number 29 on the first page there that's
an award that's given to Colonels when
they retire so we went around the room
we said who in here has a Legion of
Merit and about a half a dozen hands
went up you know who in here wants it on
their license plate all the hands went
down so we think that the we think that
the actual demand for these
awards that are are are are primarily
for doing your job but not for heroism
and other things like that we think that
demand is going to be very very low and
so that's why we would we would prefer
to see them come out uh of of this bill
uh so again I was told to just kind of
follow this but it seemed like a good
opportunity because this is the first
time I've testified for your committee
this year to tell you kind of who it is
what we and what we do at the state
veterans advisory committee you're more
than welcome to join us at any one of
our meetings we typically meet the
second two or the first Tuesday of every
month at the uh the cross training
center in Pembroke at five o'clock and
the other thing I want to do is just
kind of throw out there if you're going
to co-sponsor a bill or sponsor a bill
that has veteran involvement please let
us know we'd be more than happy to help
you word Smith language or tell you
about whether this thing that you're
pres you're proposing has been tried in
the past and if it didn't work before
why it didn't work before we'd be we're
a resource that you folks can use and so
we're subject to my any questions that
you have that's all I wanted to tell you
thank you very much always good to see
somebody from Hooksett yes sir
um any questions from the committee
I just have one thank you it's safe to
say if lines 21 through 29 were amended
out of the bill you possibly would have
a position though if you amend those
lines out the state veterans advisory
committee will support this Bill yes
thank you very much sir yes sir
I've seen no other questions thank you
again
uh next up chair recognizes I'm going to
say Eric painter uh representing himself
supporting of the bill uh looking for
did I say it right Eric painter
Piner sorry
thank you for letting me testify in
front of the transportation committee
for the record my name is Eric power I'm
a resident of Brookline in the southern
part of the state and I support this
bill
um you have a handout in front of you
that talks about HB 163 a pictorial
it shows
the top 21 metals that we have in the
United States military
from the Medal of Honor through the
Purple Heart and everything in between
on the left side you'll see stars that
indicate the current RSA 21c4 that shows
the available decals today
and then you see in green the bill
which is proposing to add a number of
decals so that every
every decal or every award in the top 21
is available for fairness to members of
the military that have earned these
Awards
on the second page I wanted to mention
that um
there was some research done on what is
happening in the other 50 states and of
these of this list here how many are
done by each state and you can see
there's quite a lit there's quite a
variance here there's some as low as
just two
um all the way up to 20. and so there's
New Hampshire is basically in the middle
we're about average
um there's 25 states that offer them
less than us and we're kind of in the
middle as if there's the the balance or
more and there's some tied with New
Hampshire
so I think this bill whatever form it
goes forward in should add to the number
that we offer more than six and i would
support that
um down below you'll see the service
seals of our six current military
services
the space force was founded in December
of 2019 and it was um
uh hasn't been added to this bill I know
there was another bill I think it was
hb206 that is recognizing the space
force and some other legislation but not
in this so I think it's it's wise not to
leave our what they call Guardians in
so the other piece I want to mention is
um I'm also a veteran myself I served
for 30 years in the Air Force both in
the Air National Guard in the Air Force
Reserve and
um
so I have a background in what the
metals mean and um I myself am a
recipient of two Legions of Merit just
to let you know about that so when I saw
this that that was let F lift out as
well as all the distinguished service
medals I would um
I was wondering why that happened
because
there are metals below that that are
offered but not ones above it so it
seems a matter of fairness that if you
happen to
earn one of these medals
distinguished medals these are not
easily earned for folks that serve in
the military they're reserved as they
said for for Colonels Navy captains and
Coast Guard captains and
um and some one two three four-star
generals for some of the higher ones
the the Legion of Merit is sometimes
awarded to very senior senior enlisted
in e-9 maybe serving as a command
sergeant major or a command chief Master
Sergeant or equivalent Master Chief in
the Navy
and um so those those Awards those folks
have sacrificed Decades of service so I
think it makes Fair it's fair for them
they didn't have a single heroic act a
single Valor maybe they'd never had the
opportunity but they did dedicate
Decades of service to their country so
that's why I think that those are
included they're also higher ranking in
the Precedence than some of the others
that are on the list so I think it makes
sense to consider those to pass the bill
as recommended
um I think that
New Hampshire wants to be
take care of our veterans recognize our
veterans allow them to have that that
decal because it can spark a
conversation and say wow what what is
this distinguished service medal that
you have what is this
airman's medal that you have what is
this soldier's medal that you have
um some people don't want to have that
some people do some people are very
private some people are very proud of it
so leaving that option open for all of
the metals that are listed here in this
bill I think is a wise move and would
honor veterans give them the choice
whether they want the decal or not
they're not that many that would be
awarded so I don't think it's a major
expense for the for the uh for the state
and I would recommend that you pass this
to pass Auto committee thank you I'll
take any questions
thank you sir questions from the
committee
seeing them thank you again thank you
uh that's the last speaker I have signed
up on House Bill 163 FN I'm going to
close the public hearing
uh next up we've got House Bill 646 FN
assistant
all right Welcome Back Being 10 33 I'm
going to open up the public hearing on
uh chair recognizes representative Tom
mannon to introduce the bill good
morning sir good morning
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Tom mannion I
represent Hillsboro District One Pelham
I'm here to introduce House Bill 646
eliminating the vehicle inspection
mandate for non-commercial vehicles
I'll start with a small story a few
years back I was driving up 495 with my
when my alternator gave out I coasted
across multiple Lanes of traffic and
managed to pull over safely as I awaited
AAA I looked over at my car inspection
sticker not even a month old these
stickers do not give a force field of
safety they do not guarantee a car will
make it a year without problems what
they do however is create headaches for
the rest of us and burden low-income
families disproportionately
these families stretch car lifetimes
because they have to
when presented with a list of nitpicky
problems that must be addressed to get
state-sponsored gold star they'll just
continue to operate with a rejection
sticker and eat whatever potential fines
because it's cheaper than repairs or
buying a new vehicle only 14 states
require annual safety inspections 14.
safety's inspections is also a misnomer
the governor the government
accountability office published a study
that showed no correlation between
vehicle crashes and inspection mandates
in fact 94 percent of vehicle crashes
are caused by driver error with
mechanical failure being two percent and
like my Dodge Avenger on 495 those
failures can still occur with an
inspection sticker
so we're introducing a burden onto
drivers with no provable benefit direct
dollar Compares components aside there's
a Time cost as well these stations are
open during average working hours
requiring taking time off to get our
permission slips so hourly workers are
not only paying the cost of the
inspection and potential repairs but
losing out on wages for the time
required to get it done
the other argument I've been hearing is
about the inspections from an emissions
standpoint nature.com released a study
outlining that in 2020 when most of the
industrialized countries locked down
production vast quantities of
individuals were no longer commuting the
global CO2 emission levels were only
slowed by at most 7.5 percent
think about how we're still reeling from
supply chain shortages the evisceration
of small businesses rampant inflation
and teasing of a global recession and we
barely moved the needle for CO2
and the EPA thinks emissions testing
Granite State or sedans is Justified
they have their scary extortion threats
that they'll just keep our tax money and
not pay for the highways so we're
operating a program out of fear of
federal retribution causing Granite
Staters money to comply with yet another
overreaching mandate from D.C and
there's enough evidence from 2020 to
conclude that it doesn't even serve the
intended purpose over half the states
don't require emissions testing I guess
Florida doesn't have highways or dense
urban areas that the EPA claims requires
annual testing
back to the supply chain shortages for a
moment for a moment uh during the last
few years getting parts required to
repair Vehicles has experienced waves of
difficulty how are you supposed to bring
your vehicle up to compliance when Parts
aren't available
do the police take this into account and
just look the other way
all the fear-mongering about cars
exploding into Rusty shrapnel or
whatever the argument is on the highways
is on hold
or are we not supposed to drive to work
until the supply chain is corrected what
if I'm part of the supply chain I can't
legally drive my vehicle to deliver the
car parts to fix my car
I think it's time to join the 36 other
states that do not require annual safety
inspections I urge you to vote OTP on
hb646 I'll take your questions
thank you representative any questions
from the committee
I just have one what did you say failed
uh my alternator an alternator yep thank
representative sellers thank you chair
so you mentioned this inspection
stickers and I and I tend to agree with
you it's for One Moment In Time
so when they inspect it it's perfect
everything's great you drive out the
door and something could happen that's
any other questions from the committee
next up chair recognizes Rebecca oler
from the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services as opposed to the
bill looking for three minutes
welcome
yep click on the microphone
Rebecca uller Department of
Environmental Services
um and and yes the department is opposed
to this bill
light duty vehicles and medium duty
vehicles are the number one source of
air pollution in the state of New
Hampshire the primary pollutants that
are of concern are both particulate
matter as well as the nitrogen oxide and
and volatile organic compounds that are
emitted they react in the presence of
sunlight and form ground level ozone
which is a very strong respiratory
irritant and can be in summertime get
high enough so that we put out air
quality action days that recommend that
that children and people with uh with
respiratory issues and elderly not go
outside we still do have days like that
in New Hampshire in the summer we have
far fewer now than we did in the past
the one of the key reasons for that is
because we've implemented an onboard
diagnostics inspection program and
annually of all light duty and medium
duty Vehicles need to pass that
inspection
and that inspection ensures that the
vehicle's emission control system is
working as designed by the manufacturer
this doesn't get to the safety portion
of the inspection and I'm sure others
will will speak to that
um the the Department's position on this
is just related to the emissions that
come out we've seen a significant
reduction in emissions from the
Transportation sector over the years as
a result we are in compliance with
Federal standards now however under the
Clean Air Act the measures that a state
takes to get into compliance with the
federal standard must remain in place to
ensure that we stay in compliance with
that standard
um as you see in our testimony letter
um and Jessica will you hand that I'm
sorry Joe we've had a testimony letter
coming out
um
if our our
vehicle inspection program was submitted
as a as a Federal attainment Tool
and uh was approved by the Environmental
Protection Agency even if New Hampshire
were to stop implementing uh our vehicle
inspection OBD program technically the
the EPA could come in and and enforce
its uh continued operation in the state
it's unlikely that they would do that
but it would cause a big
it would cause a big headache for the
state I'll stop at that and if anybody
has any questions I'd be happy to answer
them
thank you any questions from the
committee
seeing that representative Abu sorry
thank you Mr chairman Miss ulnar
um
how many states have an OBD type of
program do you know the answer to that
I'm sorry I don't know the answer to
that could that be gotten for us yes
okay I would appreciate it thank you
representative sellers
thank you Mr chair
out of the we just heard previous
testimony saying there's 36 states that
don't require uh inspection how do they
get away with that as far as the uh
Environmental Services well not every
state has experienced non non-compliance
with the federal ground level ozone
standards so some of the states probably
were not required to have the onboard
diagnostic gnostics inspection to begin
with
um
uh and other than that I don't know I
again I don't know the exact number of
states that have it but I will find that
out and get that information to the
committee
further questions from the committee
representative Sinclair thank you Mr
chair is I want to I'm not really sure
about this but is the entire State of
New Hampshire under the same rules for
emission controls
they the entire state is and this was
the result of sort of an interesting
um bartering with the EPA when when we
were first required to implement a
onboard diagnostics inspection program
the requirement was for the southern
four counties which was where our our
major non-attainment was we had periodic
elevated levels in the North country
um the requirement was for a dynamometer
style testing where you actually put
your you know drove your vehicle in and
it and it they would turn it on and
actually drive it on this Dyna
dynomometer and do tailpipe put a probe
right in the tailpipe that was right
around the same time that the onboard
diagnostic system was was incorporated
into all light duty vehicles and so we
basically made a bargain with the EPA
and said
rather than do this really intrusive
program in the southern half of the
state
um the the OBD inspection only takes a
few minutes it's you know it's it's um
much quicker it's actually also more
effective at catching pollute catching
malfunctions before they cause
significant pollution and so as part of
that negotiation New Hampshire
implemented a Statewide program with the
less intrusive inspection requirement
rather than tailpipe dynamometer testing
in just the southern four counties
a follow-up
thank you are you familiar with the
states that that don't have a vehicle
inspection and I'll use Colorado as an
example that have Machinery placed
around especially metropolitan areas
such as Denver that will pick up
exhaust from Vehicles as they go by and
they're able to identify the vehicle by
their rear license plate and send out a
notice to the vehicle owner that they
need to get in and get that emissions
fixed I'm not aware of that
um
I I would it sounds like that probably
is only addressing visible emissions
because it's probably spy camera because
I do you know I no it's it's actual they
they actually the tailpipe they're able
to grab that don't ask me how but they
okay they do I'm having a hard time
figuring out how that would work but no
I'm not familiar with that all right
I have one question
um
are any federal funds at Jeopardy if
this bill were to pass and if so how
much Highway fund money
uh
I don't know from Federal Highway
um
I'm sorry I don't know the answer to
that from the I I work primarily with
the Environmental Protection Agency
and
um I don't I'm not aware of funding that
would be
impacted by this although they could
they could reduce our clean air funding
um if we were to not implement this okay
is that something you could look into as
well absolutely thank you representative
Coker
are there uh in states that do have
these uh the emissions inspections is it
always required to be an annual
inspection are there other programs that
other states might have and still stay
I'm not sure I know the answer to that
what are the questions from the
committee
do you want to follow up okay and what
would be the consequences I mean other
than financial consequences is there any
other consequences that we would have if
we dropped out of the CPA program I mean
is it
like is is there teeth behind it or I'm
just trying to understand
you know other than obviously the good
environmental impact what being in the
good graces does yes I actually so now
that now that you frame it that way the
EPA or EPA could sanction the state and
and reduce some of our funding
um I think that the the but the
important a very important aspect is
that we also would be exposing our
children and our elderly and our and our
people with respiratory issues to
unnecessarily high levels of pollution
um I I think that dot will get in I mean
a DMV will get into uh failure rates I'm
not sure if they're going to talk
specifically about the onboard
diagnostics aspect or just safety but
um we do see even brand new vehicles
even you know 2022 or 2023 vehicle will
sometimes fail the onboard diagnostics
check and
uh in many ways that's doing the the
owner of that vehicle a service because
it might not have gotten to the point
yet where it's triggered that check
engine light but it it can potentially
do additional damage to other components
if allowed to go unrepaired
thank you appreciate it
any other questions
no that's fine we do have a is it EPA
related directly or a air directly
because we have a lot of other
specialists in the room
go ahead go ahead
are you aware of any programs that could
assist
any low-income people who fail
inspection for these reasons
that's not an area that I work in I'm
not specifically aware of any
thank you
uh chair recognizes some Alicia Brinson
uh representing new car in opposed to
the bill
sorry just wasn't aware if this was on
but um my name is Alicia Brinson I've
actually worked in the automotive
industry for about 10 years now I'm
currently the service Lane manager at
new car auto mall in Tilton I started my
journey off as a technician so I
formally was a licensed inspector so I
actually did want to touch upon some of
the specific things that the gentleman
stated on the opposing view so he stated
that it looks like he ended up on the
side of the road in his Dodge Avenger
due to an alternator that had failed I
just wanted to specify that this is an
electrical component there's
realistically no way that any mechanic
inspector could gauge the usable life of
that alternator that would essentially
be like us going to the doctors and
stating hey how long am I going to live
obviously that's not something the
doctor could Supply us with factually
um if a mechanical part's broken
obviously it's not going to work all of
the time if there's an electrical
component that's failing once again
there's no way to physically be able to
gauge its usable life
um a lot of times too electrical
components might work intermittently at
the end of their lifetime so once again
I just don't necessarily see the
Viewpoint of this gentleman trying to
state that his inspection sticker had
any influence on the fact that he was on
the side of the road with a failed
alternator
even further so I know he discussed some
things like compliance of time it's
difficult for you know what I mean
anybody to find time off of work to
comply to inspection needs realistically
dealerships are open a length of hours
even inspection stations are open until
six o'clock shuttle services you could
drop off your car have your vehicle
inspected pick it up at the end of your
work day get a shuttle service get a
shuttle ride or like get somebody within
your family your friends your workplace
to bring you to a facility to have your
inspection done so I'm not necessarily
seeing the fact that it's an
inconvenience or a Time
sensitive item there's a lot of things
that inspection stations put in place in
order for people to be able to do the
simple thing which is inspect their
he also did State something about Parts
a lot of parts being on back order or
not readably available this is a
hindrance with a lot of OEM Parts
however we do have the bandwidth to use
used parts aftermarket parts Rayman
parts so how much of the problem is that
in my professional opinion it's not a
large enough problem to create a
conflict there's many different ways to
overcome the Obstacle of not having a
part especially with how many you know I
mean local places where it's Auto Zone
other Auto Parts places Bow auto parts
use Parts aftermarket parts they're all
readily available to us and how many
parts are interchangeable from one
vehicle to another where we could use
those
so I think that's basically what I
wanted to say to argue that gentleman's
Point
um I don't necessarily see the Viewpoint
as a perspective a lot of it's just
one-offs how much of the problem is it
is it 10 is it five percent
and in my professional opinion it
doesn't necessarily seem like it's
enough of a problem in that one
situation or even the viewpoints that he
said so Parts availability time and an
electrical component that failed
thank you questions from the committee
representative sellers
thank you Mr chair
so the same question I asked the other
gentleman is the inspection sticker is
for that moment in time
would you agree
yes and no so there are wearable items
that can be measured like Brakes and
Tires putting in perspective to 30
seconds for tires or below would cause
the vehicle to fail inspection for
brakes same thing so it is a moment in
time but there are wearable items that
we can measure so example if the brakes
measure at two thirty seconds at that
time or the tires measure at 2 30
seconds at that time
that is live however
we can obviously know that a year's time
those tires are going to be
significantly lower
even if tires come in measuring putting
in perspective at 5 30 seconds
realistically depending on the average
driver 10 12 000 miles a year those
tires might actually be shot before the
well follow-up so another part of that
question is
does new car and do other dealers that
you know of especially you work for new
car you said right
do they guarantee a warranty the
inspection up until the next inspection
year
you do not that was the answer
sorry I didn't know if he like I'm sorry
I didn't know if he cut me off and I
couldn't speak further but I was
actually going to State we measure
components on a scale of green yellow
and red so of course the inspection laws
are pretty much black and white the
conversation would be your vehicle
doesn't fail for safety requirements
however this may be of concern and we
can make an advisement for the guest or
customer to take care of those needs but
it is black and white if it fails it
fails if it passes it passes but we do
give that further analogy to the
customer
I've got one question I was going to
save it for the Department of Safety but
I think you're probably going to be able
to answer real easy is an alternator or
a generator even part of a safety
inspection
it is not thank you
any other questions from the committee
representative Coker thank you Mr
chairman
um so for when a car comes in for like a
routine like service type like an oil
change or something like that I've you
know most places give out I remember the
like the kind of red green whatever
um you know on parts that are wearing
out what do you think the compliance is
for people you know like when you give
that information to customers do most
customers act on it especially when
you're like hey this is in the red area
this is like or do they kind of do you
see them blow it off like what is your I
guess opinion on that I wouldn't say
they blow it off on average I'd say it's
about 50 percent yeah so but they do get
the information you know most I mean
most cars come in for oil changes every
six months or so you know or at least
yearly and they get that information on
what's wearing off on their car correct
representative Schultz thank you
um
so does new car have any sort of fund to
help people that are low income that
fail inspection and if not how do you
work with people who obviously have
significant financial
um constraints
so to elaborate upon that we do have
finance options it's actually through a
program called sunbit we can't guarantee
what the customer would get approved for
obviously it's something that they would
have to try and we'd have to see the
result we do also have Factory Goodwill
so we have five different franchises
within those franchise franchises excuse
me obviously if the customer the guest
had loyalty we could ask the
manufacturer to assist or even depending
on the Loyalty of the guest we might
even implement or extend
um
herbestoa gesture upon the customer to
help them financially with that obstacle
I mean representative Schultz I see the
direction of your questioning I think
when the Department of Motor Vehicles
comes up they can probably answer your
question a lot more accurately not not
sure weren't accurate but I think she
can be more they can be more specific
sellers we have seven more cards
um and they're all experts in the room
would you want one more question
I just want to confirm like I said
before there's no way you can guarantee
a warranty and inspection it's only for
that good for that one moment in time
correct correct
she recognizes Bill Gurney from Gurney's
Auto opposed to the bill looking for
welcome
good morning Mr chairman matters of the
members of the committee my name is Bill
Gurney my wife and I own Gurney's
automotive repair in Nashua New
Hampshire in Milford
uh I've been doing this for 48 years or
so
um
you'll hear
statistics States
um I'm a professional technician
I'm AC Master Certified
I've looked at
tens of thousands of cars
over the years
the New Hampshire state inspection
program
is a program that increases safety on
the road
we talk about
can we guarantee
that that car is going to be safe in a
year
I can't guarantee anything out of my
control
I will tell you that
common sense for me if I ask a question
of the committee and Mr chairman if I
said if we eliminate state inspections
in the state of New Hampshire will the
roads be more safe or will they be less
safe
this isn't about just safety of that
motor vehicle and that person is driving
it
it's about the safety of your family
if someone's driving a car
and those tires which are a big thing
especially on the rear of that car are
not
conforming to what they should be
you have zero when I say zero you have
zero control of that car when it breaks
loose from the rear that car will go 360
degrees and you will have zero ability
to control it
I have driven a car
in control conditions at Michelin
Training Center
on a track
with tires on the back of the car
and when that car goes you will not and
you won't be able to protect yourself
we see
people come in
their thankful
that we have noticed something in a car
and it could be a brand new car it could
be three months old if you hit a curb
you hit a pothole and you put a blemish
in that tire
you won't know that
but that's how it could be a maypop May
it's the best deal on Main Street to
have your vehicle looked at by a
professional technician once a year
confidence that it's going to be
safe for your family
again
I have looked at
tens of thousands of cars over my
lifetime
and people
some are aware of things and they don't
want to fix them absolutely
some people get aware of them they want
but if you're a grandchild
is in the car ahead of that person with
the bad tires
you will not
ever recover from that
I am certainly open to any questions
um regarding this but again are the
roads safer
or less safe by eliminating the statue
thank you thank you sir questions from
the committee
representative
thank you for taking my question Mr
Gurney how um what percentage can you
give me me a ballpark figure of what
percentage of vehicles that come into
I wouldn't give you a figure that I'm
not comfortable I cannot give you that
figure I know the state has the figure
of the failures
um I could get that figure if you asked
me to and I could get that to the
committee but I don't want to make
something up I'm not a person that will
I don't want to guess okay all right can
I have just
um did you want to follow up yes please
um
what kinds of things are are Vehicles
most likely to fail on
you know tires are certainly a big one
brakes are certainly a big one uh
suspension parts yeah steering and uh
suspension parts certainly a big one
um
in New England and New Hampshire rust
structural rust so
you look at
the frames on some of these cars and we
have inspected cars that we tell
customers listen they're not safe for
your family do not fix and we don't want
you to fix it we don't want them to
spend money with us we want them to get
a different car they're not
safe for the road and they don't know
that because a frame as long as it's
together you're not going to see it as
soon as you get an accident and and that
rear bump is support or that rear frame
that guy folds up like an accordion and
you lose a child
what are the questions from the
committee
representative Gorski thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr Gurney for
taking my question my question kind of
dovetails Representative stobs question
how many cars have you seen
in regards to inspections that you've
said to yourself oh my goodness this car
should not be in the road
oh again I don't have a number so
whatever I say is subjective a lot I
mean
there are cars that should not be on the
road and not for us to fix they
shouldn't be on the road period and
someone's going to get hurt or someone
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much sir
thank you thank you for your time Mr
chairman thank you for your time members
of the committee
uh next up chair recognizes Bob Scully
from New Hampshire Motor Transport
Association opposed to the bills seeking
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is Bob
Scully president New Hampshire Motor
Transport Association I just want to
clarify it's um a point on here so
in the methodology section of the bill
they do
Define what a commercial motor vehicle
is so just so the committee understands
the definition of commercial Motor
Vehicles start at ten thousand pounds
so trucks between ten thousand pounds
and 26 000 pounds according to this
proposed piece of legislation would be
exempt okay and that would violate
um Federal code I'll give you the exact
396.17 in the federal quota regulations
sites those vehicles that have to be
inspected annually so so we would be in
violation at least the industry that I
represent a federal law if you pass this
bill at least with that language in it
and then my second concern
which is different than other speakers
is on your fiscal impact you know the
loss of 4.2 million dollars in a highway
fund
um the house Public Works committee
deals more with some of the highway
funding issues but with the reduction in
the highway fund the electric vehicles
the hybrid vehicles that travel on our
on our roads um
the highway fund monies are slowly
dwindling so I would offer to you that I
think this is a grave concern so those
are the two reasons why I pose this
piece of legislation
thank you very much any questions from
the committee
representative Sinclair thank you Mr
chair I I maybe I'm missing something
but reading this bill
online two it says the director may
require the inspection of any vehicle
which requires a commercial driver's
license to operate
don't you have to have a commercial
driver's license for everything 10 000
pounds and up in my correct for that no
you don't have to have a commercial
driver's license for that you need a
commercial driver's license for vehicles
over twenty six thousand pounds you need
to be in drug testing over twenty six
thousand pounds you can drive eight
commercial motor vehicle under 26 000
pounds with a regular operator's license
follow up
yeah go ahead I I I guess I guess it's
been my bad experience to be stopped in
in a box truck by state police
inspectors
um who think that my truck is over ten
thousand pounds uh in which it's not but
that's the first thing they look at is
is the is the weight and and they're
asking me for a CDL so I guess my
question is is everybody else aware of
that
I'm looking for folks from the
Department of Safety here they can
answer that question
um I'm I would tell you I'm terribly
surprised that you've had a 10 000 pound
vehicle when I asked for a CDL license
thank you you can hold on to that one
till we get safety
seeing no other questions thank you very
next up chair recognizes Dan Goodman
from AAA
the card says you support the bill and
would you like me to change it yes
yeah uh my my apologies uh for the
record my name is Dan Goodman I
represent AAA of Northern New England
and we we are here in opposition to the
bill
um I guess I was just in a rush to get
here I was all excited
um we historically advocate for bills
that make New Hampshire roads safer
and that is the sole reason why we here
we feel that if you repeal the vehicle
inspection uh mandate this will make the
roads for all users less safe uh back in
1966 AAA helped draft the national
highway safety act which was the
included in that was the first national
standards for motor vehicle inspections
and we recognized back in 1966 and we
recognized in 2023 the importance of
vehicle inspections they keep our roads
safe they are very vital to keep our
road safe in fact
um each year AAA Automotive
professionals and sometimes myself we
travel around New Hampshire and we do
free pre-winter checkups that are
different branches throughout the state
where we check brakes steering
components lights tires and other issues
and I'm usually a one checking the tire
gauges that's my experience that's as
much as my expertise is and at these
events I can tell you we see countless
ball tires bad brakes
bad exhaust systems and we hear
countless times people just asking you
sure we can't get through the winter
with these tires or these ball tires and
I mean we're there just advising them
and trying to help them prepare for the
winter
um so we see it firsthand hundreds of
times every winter
um and as was mentioned previously we
think this is a fantastic deal to have a
trusted professional mechanic look at
your vehicle for a very good deal they
conduct a very comprehensive inspection
on your vehicle for a modest price so
I'll just end with that that we oppose
this and we I'm happy to answer any
questions
thank you sir questions from the
committee representative Coker
I thank you Mr chairman uh so do you
would you say that there's a lot of
availability for
anybody you know anybody with a vehicle
to get their car inspected
um you know without some kind of a
mandate I mean it seems like there's you
know the routine oil changes but there's
just so many touch points that most
people are going to get their car
inspected at
um do you think that people would would
do that less if there wasn't an
inspection yearly
thank you for the question that's a
little beyond my expertise there are
people from the from the dealers and uh
uh that could answer that better but I
would say in highway safety whether it's
impaired driving laws teen driver laws
um there's to change people's behaviors
it takes three legs that we call it like
the the stool you have education
um engineering and enforcement so
without that enforcement you don't
change behavior and so we feel if like
there wasn't that that mandate that that
behavior wouldn't change and they would
drive with unsafe Vehicles all right
thank you
what are the questions
representative Sinclair thank you Mr
chair it's very nice to see you again
and I'm going to ask you the same
question I asked you you may remember
the last time you testified you said the
AAA is opposed to this are we talking
about the AAA membership or are we
talking about the AAA board of directors
thank you for the question it's great to
see you as well and I appreciate the
question
um it never it never gets old I'm happy
to answer
um every every bill
um so AAA before we started helping
everyone the 527 000 members of New
Hampshire roadside we started as a a
public policy advocacy organization that
that's where our roots are before we're
helping people in emergency roadside it
was a it was a group of individuals who
the roads were not suitable for cars
they were suitable for horses and so
they got together and they advocated
their state legislators and the national
legislators to let's work on making the
roads safer for vehicles
um so we've always been advocating for
policies to make our roads and highways
safer for all users so that's just been
in our roots to always and I know it's
for some people it's it's we're they're
curious on why we're there but we feel
that's in aaa's DNA to advocate for
policies uh relate we feel like the
sure follow-up thank you but you didn't
answer my question uh directly I I want
to know did you take a survey of the
members of AAA in the state of New
Hampshire with regards to this bill or
is this something that in their your
safety thoughts the board of directors
thank you for the question I would say
that we did not survey members on this
issue
thank you
representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
Goodman for uh actually all I want was
you mentioned three stooled leg
three-legged stool
got that slightly backwards but I only
caught two of them so could you just
repeat the all three
thank you for the question
representative engineering enforcement
okay
an edge of sellers
thank you Mr chair
so the would you say it's true that
these vehicles that you're seeing you
know that you do these somewhat
pre-inspections with with bad tires or
something else going wrong with them
these are vehicles that have already
been inspected previously
sometime during the year
thank you for the question
that is something that we don't we don't
seeing no other questions thank you very
much
foreign
next up chair recognizes Tracy borovash
from the New Hampshire motorcyclist
rights organization uh opposed to the
bill looking forward three minutes to
speak thank you
welcome
good morning or the afternoon now with
all the minutes
thank you chairman Walsh and committee
members I am Tracy borvage I'm the
president of a New Hampshire motorcycle
rides organization also known as an hmro
and we are in opposition of this bill
I want to give you a quick synopsis of
why
the last time an industry survey was
done by the motorcycle inspection
failure people to be able to inspect
motorcycles it was roughly 30 percent of
the motorcycles that failed inspections
how a rider rides determines how a back
tire of a motorcycle wears
that's a statement you want to think
about a little bit how much weight a
rider carries on their motorcycle
is a factor
how many miles they put on it is a
factor and every Rider rides different
and every Rider rides a lot differently
in a summertime or a season and seasons
are different for every Rider
unfortunately most Riders do not know
how to to check their their tire tread
depth most motorcycles don't even know
how to check a lot of things on their
motorcycle especially anymore we have a
lot of new riders coming in
writing especially in the with what's
happened and occurred with the pandemic
we have a lot of new riders coming in
they don't know how to work on their
motorcycles they know how to check
anything on their motorcycles and that's
um it doesn't take much truly to the
imagination to think about the tragic
consequences on a motorcycle if our tire
or our brake system fail
those are two things that are key
important elements when we get our
also
representing the motorcycles we want to
know that the other vehicles obviously
on the roadways are inspected because
when we're on the roadways with them we
certainly don't want someone's brakes to
fail and take us out so that's important
to us as well
and I want to share with you something
that's important
being part of nhmro that we're proud of
we started a motorcycle safety task
force along with the Department of
Safety
we started this we brought in the New
Hampshire of Highway uh safety we
brought in the State Police we brought
in AAA of Northern New England New
Hampshire Automobile Dealers Association
I heart media The Liquor Commission the
writers education program
and we started the ride smart safety
program which has now been about adopted
by the state and it's actually going to
end up being adopted by Nitza
and we talk about writing smart
safely or totally aware excuse me
respectfully entrained and our key
component would safely talks about
checking our tires our brake systems but
we can't do that alone the Riders are
just not capable of doing that they're
not they're not going to most writers
will get on their motorcycle at the
beginning of that season and not think
about checking their tires they just
don't and I'm going to tell you as
president of New Hampshire motorcycle
rights and my husband's sitting right
here behind me a lot of times I don't I
just I get on that motorcycle I want to
I'm anxious to get on it and I just
don't take a look at that tire
so we believe in the inspections we
believe that they do work and they are
important
so we are in opposition the other one
last component of this is that 4.2
million dollars that we lose to protect
our roads
our roads up here quite frankly
sometimes suck for us as motorcyclists
we need our roads to be safe for us to
ride so it's a key important to keep
that money in the highway safety fund so
we have safe roads for us
thank you
thank you questions from the committee
representative Crawford thank you Mr
chair could I get a copy of that of the
right smart yes please yes I can leave
this with you if you want thank you
for the questions from the committee
seeing then thank you very much thank
you
uh next up chair recognizes in support
of the bill
Mary Smith representing herself seeking
greetings
greetings thank you Mr chair
um
uh thank you chair and committee for
taking the time to hear my testimony
today
um
I'd like to start out by saying or
asking who is responsible for your
safety
is the government responsible for your
is it someone else is it the police is
it your parents is it your spouse who is
responsible for your safety
uh driving is uh essentially the most
dangerous activity that I know of that
uh people engage in on a regular basis
and
I just want to bring some figures from
the national highway
traffic safety administration uh into
this conversation to help
guide our understanding of exactly what
sort of good or bad this bill could do
[Music]
um
according to the national highway
traffic safety administration
um
42 915 people died
um and fatal car crashes in 2021 that
um now if we assumed all of those people
were residents of New Hampshire that
would be about three percent of our
population
but that's the entirety of the United
States so that's about uh point zero one
percent of the population of the entire
United States okay what were the causes
according to the national highway
traffic safety administration they said
the causes were drunk driving lack of
seat belt use speeding distracted
driving and drowsy driving
okay removing
the state inspections addresses uh
exactly none of these okay the state
inspections they're not inspecting uh
that drivers are awake while they're
driving they're not inspecting drivers
are not drunk while they're driving
they're not inspecting drivers uh seat
belts if the seat belts work or if they
put their seat belts on
New Hampshire's motto here is Live Free
or Die
and I think
uh as exemplified by our lack of a uh
seat belt law
New Hampshire legislators trust New
Hampshire residents to be responsible
for their own safety
so that is uh the main potatoes of my
testimony I'm willing to take any
questions but I'm just a member of the
public
the most important members
um any questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much
foreign
next up chair recognizes Dan Bennett New
Hampshire Auto Dealers Association
opposed to the bill
welcome
members of the committee uh I will be
ready
um I do have a handout uh there's some
pretty pictures on there but there's
also some really good data that I'd like
you all to see I'll make reference to in
my testimony again Dan Bennett New
Hampshire Auto Dealers Association and
Hada is a trade group representing the
motor vehicle industry we are 500
businesses uh car trucks snowmobile ATV
construction farm equipment Collision
repairs amongst others so
once again as always nhada opposes this
legislation we have in the past for the
multiple times it's been
presented including when we opposed it
last year when this committee wisely
italed the bill 18 nothing and it uh
passed the house on the consent calendar
so a few points that I'll mention
um vehicle inspections catch recalls
that save consumers money okay the
safety inspection program that we have
in New Hampshire last year alerted
citizens to 200 over 224 000 open safety
recalls on their vehicles those are open
safety recalls whose cost to repair are
covered by the manufacturer so the
vehicle inspection program New Hampshire
actually saves saves consumers money
the Nitza studies show the mechanical
defects or worn equipment on vehicles
was a causative or aggravating factor in
12.6 percent
crashes so that's a pretty high
percentage
the New Hampshire rate actually went up
last year it's now at 14.4 percent you
can see from the chart on the back we
have a year-over-year comparison
including the items that information
graciously surprised supplied by the DMV
a Pennsylvania study in 09 concluded
that safety inspections play a
significant role in saving lives uh it
stated that the Pennsylvania inspection
program has reduced the number of fatal
crashes by 115 to 169 saving 127 to 177
lives on an annual basis so it's our
opinion that if the safety inspection
program saves one life it's worth it so
I don't know what the acceptable number
would be based on stuff that I've heard
so preventative maintenance saves money
right so it's like an annual checkup
with your doctor
um you know breaks Brakes and Tires can
you know 300 repair if you have a
catastrophic failure the front end it
could cost three thousand dollars so
that simple checkup actually saves money
in the long run
um all of our neighboring states have
safety inspections
um you know you cannot compare us to
Florida or Arizona or or other states
further Evidence by the the map that I
have uh and the information comes from
dot here it's actually a winter severity
rating so some folks say uh you know
well uh Colorado and Minnesota have
snowy Winters they do but when you look
at in total the severity of the winters
we have uh 50 degree days in January and
it's going to be negative 25 this
weekend right so we have these massive
ranges so you can't really compare us to
all those others you have to look at the
New England region where a little micro
climate and you can see you know it's
actually
um you know Blazing Red meaning
incredibly severe you know a lot of
those other states Don't Spray liquid
salt water on their roads in the winter
road brine the way that we do so it does
a unique amount of damage to Vehicles
here in New Hampshire
um
it was mentioned before again uh 500 000
loss to to local municipalities and then
4.2 million dollars to the state highway
fund
um it's an incredible hold to fill
um so again this is problematic
um we did talk about the the emissions
testing system was was mentioned
um so we can talk about that you know we
do have a federal requirement to do that
annual testing the safety inspection and
the OBD2 testing process are tied
together the method with which we do
OBD2 testing and Reporting is tied to
the annual safety inspection program so
with that safety inspection goes away so
does our emissions testing program
putting us in violation and emission
reductions is a pretty simple concept
right once you get on a diet you stay on
a diet
and that's why we do it so that we don't
backslide with our clean air we may be
meeting it now but we need to make sure
that we stay that way
the bill also wipes out an issue that
you heard a few weeks ago this bill also
wipes out in all inspections for antique
vehicles
um and then the question was asked
before about low-income individuals
there's the OBD2 testing system just so
you know does have an economic hardship
waiver process through the DMV if
repairs cannot be afforded so
um sorry if I stole your thunder
um
you know I heard mention of the New
Hampshire doesn't have a seat belt law
um you know you're not wearing your
seatbelt won't kill me right but your
bad breaks in a car that's going 80 000
or 80 miles an hour that weighs 3 000
pounds potentially will so uh something
to consider you know it you've you've
got a number of roadway safety Advocates
here that that are opposed to the bill
um including Triple A nhmro the New
Hampshire Traffic Safety commission also
weighed in on this pistol legislation
they're opposed to it
um
so um
I guess really uh and trying to address
any of the questions that you all had
that's really my testimony just
um once again you know uh in the name of
of safe roads a Cornerstone issue for
nhada whether it's this or motorcycle
rider education or or the texting while
driving
um you know we we support safe roads in
New Hampshire
um and and we oppose this legislation
thank you for your testimony and it
would not be complete without a question
from representative Saint Claire
that is correct thank you Mr chair you
mentioned something that I the last time
I was on this committee I remember the
chair brought this very topic up have
your and we know that this affects
Vehicle Safety have your 500 businesses
are taking a position on this uh maybe
Banning this liquid brime that's being
put on our highways in the name of
safety
thank you for the question
representative Sinclair it's not the one
I thought that was coming but I'll do my
best
we have not taken our association has
not taken a position for or against Road
brine we have looked at the issue and
we've looked at its impact on vehicles
there was a bill filed a few years ago
but I believe by the chairman I believe
maybe turn into a study committee we
were involved and and part of and part
of that discussion
um so we're interested in following the
issue however we have not picked in a
position for or against that practice
and policy
thank you thank you before the record it
is magnesium chloride it's it's a
wonderful stuff any other questions from
the committee representative sellers
thank you Mr chair
you said uh uh you mentioned about
recalls uh
do you know if every inspection station
checks for recalls
thank you for the question as long as
the vehicle goes through the uh Gordon
Darby and host sifsum which we do OBD2
testing it's a requirement of that
program that every single vehicle that
goes through that system receives a
safety inspection so last year a total
of
uh
uh one million 237
000 and change Vehicles went through the
system and over 224 000 of them found
follow up thank you Mr chair
uh I'm just trying to be aware on on
brake systems I I believe there's at
least
a redundancy usually front brakes from
rear bearings are two different systems
so if one failed you still have the
other but on some vehicles and
especially I'm talking cars they could
even have four wheel independent braking
uh at that point so even if you had one
fill
is is it do you know if there the others
would still be working is that correct
thank you for the question I think I'd
probably rather defer that uh to someone
a little more technical than me you
bikes and skis are another issue but
not seeing any other questions thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
uh chair recognizes in support of the
welcome
hi everybody thank you for having me
um I'm here supporting myself uh or
representing myself for uh the uh to
support the bill hb646
um one of the problems with the state
inspection system is the regulations
themselves are
uh often vague
um open to interpretation
and uh
and many of them have absolutely nothing
to do with safety
um the other problem you have is there
are dishonest mechanics in the state who
uh
have tried to defraud people
um in saying they need a break job when
they clearly don't
um and one of the problems with the
state system is there's no appeal
process if you disagree
um there's really no way to uh
to get a second opinion
um
uh I actually worked for one of New
Hampshire's largest Automotive companies
uh for several years although I was not
a professional mechanic I purchased a
new vehicle from them while I was
employed there
um
and because of my birthday uh just a
couple months after I purchased it I had
to bring it in for a re-inspection and
usually I am a do-it-yourselfer who's
done pretty much everything from
transmission repairs and engine rebuilds
and welding and all sort of things and
I've usually driven older vehicles and
it's always been a hassle almost every
year for the first time I'm like all
right I got a almost brand new car it's
under warranty what could possibly go
wrong
um
I get a phone call from the service
advisor hey you need a um you need new
front brakes to pass inspection
and I'm like that's weird because when I
bought the car you guys told me it had
new brakes all the way around so either
you're lying to me then or you're lying
to me now which one is it I want to go
see those breaks for myself and I ran
into the the shop to go look at my truck
and um find the mechanic scrambling to
put the inspection sticker on my truck
and I got a written
um
uh estimate for
923 dollars
um for new breaks that turns out I
didn't need because a year later
uh when it was time to get my inspection
sticker yet again I said well they
barely passed last year
um they probably aren't going to pass
this year I should just preemptively do
them even though they haven't been
problematic yet
and I was surprised to find that
although the um
they were indeed wearing unevenly which
is what the mechanic told me was wrong
with them
um they still had well well uh over the
uh they were well well within the limit
of what you needed for breaks so I
almost you know and and I'm just
wondering well if this is what they
do to somebody they know and they know I
work on my own cars and stuff
um and they know me there uh what are
they doing to your average grandmother
who doesn't really know better and is
going to just take their word for it you
know I could have been out an
unnecessary nine hundred dollars when I
could have probably gotten even more
time out of those breaks
and
um
uh there's a I've emailed all of you
there's a list of states that have
already gotten rid of their inspection
processes New Hampshire is only one of a
few states that still has one
um and I don't think we need it anymore
and I think that the risk to
[Music]
um fraud and uh
and the other problem is sometimes
people are like I just need to get one
more year out of my car or six months
out of my car I'm just trying to save
every penny I can to have a down payment
for my next vehicle and they can either
take you know a thousand dollars and put
it towards an unnecessary repair on the
vehicle they're planning on getting rid
of
or they could put it towards their new
car
so I think this really this uh this
really harms uh you know the poor people
of New Hampshire who
um and people who don't know their cars
thank you very much for your testimony
any questions from the committee
Lieutenant James O'Leary represent the
state police opposed to the bill seeking
five minutes
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee
we've heard a lot of testimony and
opposition at Bill and I'm not going to
repeat those points just know that we're
in support of what those were I do want
to bring to light just a different
perspective from what Troop G does and
and as we've talked about before we are
tasked for providing enforcement and
Licensing oversight to both dealerships
and inspection stations and as such we
are also the repository for consumer
complaints regarding the purchase of
unsafe motor vehicles and oftentimes
consumers will purchase a used motor
vehicle and later find that the vehicle
is unsafe for the roadway due to a
variety of reasons the vehicle
deficiencies are only discovered due to
the completion of a state mandated
inspection this is where investigators
from Troop G become involved and
depending on circumstances conduct an
investigation regarding the proper sale
of the vehicle without the mandated
state inspection that occurs at the time
of new ownership of the vehicle the
average consumer may not be aware of any
mechanical issues affecting its safe
operation furthermore it may not be
until months later when the vehicle is
brought in for service that a mechanical
issue is discovered the time that lapses
be between the time of purchase to the
revelation of such a safety issue not
only puts the consumer and the motoring
public at risk it also decreases the
probability that a buyer is held
accountable for or the seller rather is
held accountable for potential criminal
or civil penalties if warranted
although this law would not prevent
individuals from seeking an inspection
on their own the safety of our roadways
would be Reliant upon those individuals
having such an inspection conducted
I'll close with the last speaker spoke
about not having an appeals process and
that's a something that we hear about a
lot obviously because there are you know
just like in any business individuals
that you know claim work needs to be
done and what have you Troop G also is a
repository for those types of calls as
well so if somebody does have a vehicle
inspected and they don't agree with what
the outcome is we field calls regarding
those inspections such inspections and
we'll conduct an investigation upon
finding out whether or not that vehicle
should or should not have passed
inspection and proceed accordingly
thank you sir any questions from the
committee representative Jones
thank you and thank you for coming thank
you
I just want to ask the uh the attorney
general has the Department of Consumer
Affairs are they in touch with you when
these type of things happen thank you
for your question yes sir we do work in
conjunction with uh the Attorney
General's office when it comes to such
complaints
thank you
I do have one question
because I've heard the story from the
previous testimony before how would the
average person know who to contact if
they wanted to question whether or not a
a failure was was appropriate thank you
Mr chair for your question so typically
what happens is the average consumer
will go to the DMV website and they'll
find the dealer inspection number
they'll call the phone number for the
dealer inspection desk and that's how
that information gets relayed down to us
thank you for the questions yeah
representative I saw Sinclair first yep
thank you Mr chair just for the record
uh when a State Trooper makes a traffic
stop
um I they usually will see what they'll
look at the sticker normal procedure but
by seeing there's a current inspection
sticker on there do they then at that
point neglect or purposely not look at
other tires and things like that at the
particular moment of that stop thank you
representative Sinclair for your
question uh no that wouldn't be accurate
because oftentimes we'll find that there
are items that may have been changed
since then so for example if an
inspection is done and somebody changes
their tires or tints their windows or
changes their headlights or many things
uh you know factor into that we would
see that there were potential other
items that again that we could see
visibly that did not meet state
inspection criteria thank you welcome
representative representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman thank you
lieutenant O'Leary for taking my
question
in the
I'm making a presumption here so I
believe that there are posters inside
inspection stations that might talk
about the price they may talk about
procedures or whatever
is there any information on these
required if
are there required post component of the
poster to say if you have a complaint
about the procedures here to call this
number thank you representative response
for your questions there is there is not
um they are given they're supposed to be
given an outline or a quote for the
items that need to be repaired however
there is not information to my knowledge
that speaks to
um contacting either DMV or State Police
foreign
any other questions from the committee
representative Gorski thank you Mr
chairman thank you lieutenant Larry for
taking my question yes sir in terms of
handling the the appeals how many
appeals did you hear or got involved
with let's say in the past past year
thank you representative for that
question unfortunately I don't have the
answer for that so essentially what
happens for our troop those those
concerns or questions will come in or
and uh those get distributed accordingly
to the Troopers and the AIS to go up and
follow up on I just don't have the
numbers with me today but I could get
them if you'd like them sure
further questions
chair recognizes
from the Department of Motor Vehicles
are you both coming up together
okay uh director marasco and Jeff
bobadink opposed to the bill
welcome
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is John marasco I'm
the director of The Division of Motor
Vehicles along with registration
supervisor Jeff overdeck we do oppose
the bill the mission of the New
Hampshire DMV is safe drivers safe
vehicles and safe roadways our annual
inspection requirement helps us fulfill
all of those objectives the handout that
you received from Supervisor over dank
captures three years worth of data from
Gordon Darby which captures all the
inspection information throughout the
state as you'll see within that document
there are failures and categories such
as breaks steering and tires obviously
those are concerning categories that we
want to make sure Vehicles aren't on the
road if they have deficiencies in those
areas this bill when reading it
would eliminate well over a million
vehicle inspections per year and if you
also within the handout you see that
roughly a quarter million vehicles
um in any given year could have
deficiencies that would be problematic
and may translate into the vehicle not
fit for the roadway roughly 14 percent
maybe a little more than that of
vehicles don't pass the annual state
inspection and so for that we oppose the
bill we think the model that we have
works and it helps fulfill that model of
safe drivers safe vehicles and safe
roadways there are some technical
defects with the bill that supervisor
oberdeen could speak to
thank you welcome
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee and I won't uh I won't belabor
going over other pieces of testimony
that we had as a number of folks have
made those points today but what I do
want to do is a quick lesson on
commercial driver licensing and what
that means to this bill and what it
means to us when we think of CDL and
that's what this bill specifically
labels out is that those
vehicles that require a CDL would be the
only ones left in the program
um everyone thinks of the twenty six
thousand and one pound plus vehicle up
we think of the Walmart tractor trailer
the Continental Paving truck hauling
pavement down the road what we don't
think of is what uh Bob Scully mentioned
earlier and that's the the fastest
growing portion of the commercial
vehicle segment and we call them CDL
beaters because manufacturers are
manufacturing vehicles of large size
that specifically don't require a CDL so
for instance vehicles that are twenty
six thousand one pounds plus require a
cdlb
and now they're manufacturing those
exact same vehicles at 25 900 pounds so
now those drivers aren't required to go
through the CDL testing and do those
other things that other CDL drivers are
required to do but that segment that
we're talking about is a 10 0001
to 26 000 pound category think of your
plumber Sprinter van think of your uh
electrician's van or your F-450 or 550
in landscaping in that category not
required to have a commercial license
but they are required to have a medical
card and they are in the game as far as
FMCSA is concerned
so by eliminating the inspections for
those Vehicles number one it takes us
out of the pool for Federal grant money
which we just use for our new IRP
program for that apportion plate program
that we put into play that allows
carriers to do their their registrations
online that was paid for by the feds
because we are compliant didn't come out
of our pocket came out of theirs
most importantly if we're not putting
inspection stickers on those vehicles in
the ten thousand one to twenty six
thousand pound category
they can't leave the state
think about that all of those businesses
that can't leave the state because those
commercial Motor Vehicles are not
inspected
that's the outlying piece here with this
piece of legislation
it's not the 26001 plus that we're
concerned with what we are but it's a
ten thousand one to twenty six thousand
pound category because they are required
to have inspection stickers and all of
those other states that they go in
so to provide that opportunity for that
category it can remain in compliance and
be eligible for interstate commerce
we need to continue that inspection
program for that segment of vehicles as
well
having said that I'll answer any
questions the board may have
thank you any questions from the
committee representative Jones
thank you Mr chairman
um in our fiscal notes uh it says you
would be a loss of 4.2 million dollars
How would
you as a department
make up for that would you have to
increase rates somewhere else or would
you be laying people off or how would
that affect you
that part of the budget is up to three
percent of our Federal Highway funds and
where and how that's distributed is up
to the fiscal committee and who and how
thank you further questions
representative value
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um are there situations where a vehicle
might weigh more than twenty six
thousand one pounds that where you
wouldn't need a CDL to operate it that
would put it outside this inspection
requirement uh thank you for the
question it's a great question we think
of those uh all those campers that are
not involved in Commerce you have and
it's not a large segment but you do have
a number of vehicles which are above 26
000 pounds that act just like a
commercial vehicle some of those larger
Diesel Pusher motorhomes are well in
excess of 26 000 pounds that don't
require a CDL
thank you
representative sellers
are you saying that this law won't if
someone had a vehicle just under 26 000
pounds that they can't get an inspection
or could they still get an inspection so
they can go out of state
is it a requirement for them to get
inspected to go out of state they would
have to get an inspection but if we're
not doing the inspection where do they
did you want to follow it yes please
I guess I'm saying is it's not forbidden
for them to get an inspection so they
could still get one couldn't they it
depends on if other states do courtesy
inspections or not I'm talking about
honesty could we do a courtesy
inspection it's not outlined in the
legislation
um
representative Sinclair
thank you I thought what representative
Sykes brought up about uh
paperwork posters or something like that
to to for the public to know that they
have a right to appeal or complain is
that something due to fraud uh is that
something that you uh gentlemen would be
look would look into that maybe in the
future we could address that
I think that's a great suggestion I can
certainly work with Lieutenant O'Leary
on that and I'm sure that we could come
up with a plan
thank you very much thank you and thank
you for that representative Sinclair I
do have just a couple of quick ones uh
actually maybe just one
um uh we can all see the fiscal impact
of 4.225 million dollars uh we've asked
the Department of Environmental Services
to see if there's other funding in
Jeopardy uh with the Clean Air Act in
the federal government one last question
on that though uh I'm not sure when our
contract with Gordon Darby expires but
what would be the fiscal impact of
breach contract
it would uh we'd have to ask Gordon
Darby we'd have to take a look at the
contract and ask Gordon Darby that's a
that's a great question Mr chairman if
you could provide us with that it would
be great thank you sure uh any other
questions from the committee
seeing none I have nobody else signed up
to speak on this bill I'm going to close
um we are on lunch break we'll be
opening up our executive sessions at one
o'clock
foreign
good afternoon everybody
I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill 260.
and now I'm going to recess the
executive session on House Bill 260
if I can ask committee services to make
sure the stream is off please and I'm
going to have ask everybody to leave so
foreign
I'm like
involved under that or not
right
so do the other states have that is my
point so maybe that's covered under
if they well pretty good bits and piece
something else they can get your
penigulants
all right everybody welcome back to
Transportation I'm going to reopen the
executive session on House Bill 260 FN
and the chair recognizes representative
sellers for a motion
Mr chair I motion to itl this bill
thank you sir do I have a second
Ed by representative Hill how would you
basically speaking that this bill is it
the intent of the bill was good however
there wasn't any data given to us or any
statistics that would actually help us
solve the problem and also that this
bill also I believe is just really a
one-off of being distracted there you
could be distracted by many many
different things so that's why I feel
thank you very much anybody else from
so
um
I I happen to think that um
we do probably wish we had a lot more
data about this but
um one of the things one of our Prime
directives as members of the
transportation committee is to support
Public Safety for everybody and
the the public safety agencies were I
believe unanimous in their support of
this bill and so for that reason I would
anybody else from the committee
I'm going to vote against an itl motion
I apologize
well I
all right all right uh anybody else from
the committee it's representative Jones
thank you um yes there are a lot of
other safety issues that we could draw
but I think uh it's okay to go one at a
time and this is a very simple thing for
uh law enforcement to catch
um and
um
in our state the number of deaths by
motor vehicle accident is way up the
member of pedestrian deaths is way up I
think we got to start taking safety
measures in the right direction thank
you
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll the motion is itl on House Bill
Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith
yeah yes
the clerk votes yes representative Hill
yes
representative Dumas yes
representative Spillane yes
representative C
yes representative sellers yes
representative Sykes no representative
Schultz
no representative Sinclair yes
no
representative Rambo
yes
representative value
no
representative Coker
yes
representative Jones
no
representative uh
charette did I say that correctly thank
you that's correct no do it
got it did you say no
no thank you and representative Staub no
we have
13 yes and
okay our committee recommendation is 13
to 7 for an itl I'm going to close the
executive session on
house bill 260.
give us a few minutes to reset please
uh just for anybody that may be watched
remotely or hear as a professional
courtesy with some questions and
possible solutions that have Arisen I
will not be taking up house bills 374 or
375 today
just for your planning purposes I'll I
will reschedule them most likely for
yep
Mr chair
when when will reports be
do
or the bills we're expecting today yeah
today
before we go home
speaking of reports while we're getting
reset did everybody receive a copy an
electronic copy of the committee report
from our researcher
everybody's a yes
okay we can still do them by by writing
if you'd like but if you've all got them
okay I'm gonna open up the executive
session on House Bill 388fn relative to
number plates from motor vehicles uh
chair recognizes representative Smith
for a motion thank you Mr chair I move
odd to pass on House Bill 388. motions
ought to pass is there a second
by representative Hill representative
Smith if you care to speak to your
motion
yes thank you Mr chair so we understand
the bill the there's a whole paragraph
before you but the Bold italics is the
only change so this is the statute
requiring registration and plates and
the only change is and further provided
that a private passenger vehicle shall
only be required to display one number
plate on the rear of the vehicle it
doesn't say prohibited from displaying
two plates just that you're getting two
plates you only got to hang one on the
back
um for this reason I think the fiscal
note's incorrect because it does not
direct the department of safety to do
anything different than they do today
they still make two plates per vehicle
they're still going to sell two plates
per vehicle and when you get your plates
you can hang one or both
um so so that ends I don't see how
this is something that we already do in
New Hampshire just not the whole state
at once when a town has a significant
anniversary for its founding 150 years
200 250 years they are allowed for an
entire year to remove their front number
plate and replace it with a
commemorative plate there's usually a
contest for the design they're nice it's
a nice thing to do
I hear the arguments against the bill
but what I don't hear is data from large
towns where this caused any problems and
we've been doing it for quite a while
now
further our border state Vermont went
without front license plates for a while
and despite for a couple years of me
asking I have yet to hear that any of
the fears we had about complications to
law enforcement manifesting over there
um in the absence of that
after specific requests I can only
assume at this point that that data does
not exist
and on a personal note
about 22 years ago when I worked for a
Dodge Plymouth Chrysler dealer I'd only
been there a couple of weeks and we got
on a brand new Viper
and they told me to put the plastic
plate hanger bracket on the front of the
car and the way you do that is they give
you a couple of lag bolts those are big
pointy bolts and an impact gun and you
literally just drive them through the
front fascia of the car that hurt me on
a deep spiritual level Mr chair
and also significantly devalues the car
if you want to try to sell it in one of
the 20 or so states that doesn't require
a front plate because now you've got
holes there and you have to keep the
ugly gray plastic bracket they're
generally not painted to match the car
that's a special request I guess or you
do it yourself
so
in light of the fact that the fiscal
note's incorrect the zero fiscal impact
to The Spill that we've already been
doing this in New Hampshire as we cycle
through our Town's anniversaries and no
testimony was given all the problems it
caused in those towns I see no reason to
not support this bill Mr chair
thank you representative anybody else
so
um
again I'll go back to my comment about
public safety and I I try to
pay attention to what the professional
Public Safety people are telling us and
the gentleman who was representing the
New Hampshire Chiefs of police they were
in opposition to the bill Lieutenant
O'Leary from the Hampshire dos was an
option opposition to the bill
um
the majority of the states that only
require
a rear license plate are states that
have
friendlier weather than we have up here
in New Hampshire
um in addition to that
the fiscal impact that I the testimony
that I heard was from the New Hampshire
D.O.T particularly the administrator of
the Turnpike Authority
who said that this would have an adverse
effect on the collection of tolls
they collect about 13 million dollars in
tolls 53 percent of those were captured
by the front plate
and there are in addition to that 36
Lanes in the toll plazas that do not
have rear cameras so they may they may
not they may lose that um that Revenue
as well and the cost and I agree that
this seems a bit inflated to me but he
testified that the cost was four hundred
thousand dollars to put rear-facing
cameras in the toll in the 36 locations
that of lanes that do not have
rear-facing
um
uh cameras
and so I think on balance
we need to be really careful and
fiscally prudent about whenever we take
actions which will reduce the revenues
to support the the turnpikes right now
the turnpikes are reasonably
self-sufficient but
we want to make sure that they continue
to be so so I would be opposed to this
the passage of this bill
thank you anybody else from the
committee representative Sinclair thank
you Mr chair I um my issues are
the fact that manufacturers are now
putting brand new vehicles out with no
front plate so maybe we're looking at
the wave of the future here
with the other states that have already
doing this and as far as that
putting in cameras at the uh told toll
Gates that pick up the rear license
plate I I would have thought we already
have that if they're saying that 53
percent of the money is coming been
captured by the front plate are they
saying that 47 is totally lost because
there's no rear uh on on the many cars
that come into this state from states
that don't have that and as I mentioned
before all the motorcycles that only
have one rear plate so has the state
just are they just saying no we're not
going to worry about that if they need
those cameras they should already have
them there and I would agree with
representative Sykes that the price
seems a little a little inflated to me
on that so I I will be supporting this
for those reasons thank you
see
representative Jones
thank you Mr chairman
um I think as far as
um law enforcement it cuts this would
cut their ability to ID a car they need
to die they need to uh ID by 50 because
now they can only see it from the back
if they're coming forward
straightforward oncoming they can't idea
a car they may be looking for or a car
that's uh been involved in in something
um also um I had an experience
at my house uh where we had porch
Pirates and I have a ring system on my
doorbell
but
Unfortunately they pulled in forward
took the boxes off my porch and backed
right out and didn't have a front
license plate so the police were not
able to ID the vehicle so I think it's
just a matter of more security by having
two more plates having two plates thank
you sir
fair enough anybody else from the
committee
representative Sykes one more stab at it
yeah I'll take my second bite at the
Apple thank you Mr chairman
um yeah I think I didn't make enough
emphasis on the point that
having a front plate which again is more
opportunity to identify the vehicle that
may be involved in a crime and by the
way vehicles are frequently
involved in crime we don't want to take
that tool away we just don't want to
take that tool away and
um
we
can give we're given examples of how
crimes were solved because there was a
front plate even though that front plate
even though no police officer happened
to actually see the crime take place it
happened they were able to identify the
vehicle based on the evidence left
behind by the front plate specifically a
crash into a more into a home and the
impression of the numbers of the license
plate the front license plate were left
on the side of the building and that led
to solving the crime so
I I just can't imagine
that we shouldn't leave important tools
both Financial tools and public safety
tools in the hands of the agencies that
need them the amount of
we have while we may not have some data
that we want we also don't have
um
how many people how many people are
actually complaining about this
I mean I know there's a very vocal
uh group of people who complain about
having having to have the first the
front and the back plate but we've heard
no data that said well yeah there's two
percent of the drivers
do we make Law changes based on such
thank you representative that's all
speculation just like it's speculation
that these do help we've been asking for
the data for years and still we don't
have it anybody else from the committee
representative
thank you Mr chairman the only thing I
consider that Beyond and what other
people have said is
the fact that a lot of people in New
Hampshire tow trailers and that can
obscure the rear plate no matter whether
you have a rear-facing cameras or not
and you lose the revenue not only from
the vehicle but from the trailer from
the extra axle for axles so to me that's
that's one of the arguments that wasn't
fair enough anybody else
yeah Representatives Blaine
well just to point out that a lot of
people in the state also drive with
plows on the truck
totally obscuring the front plate and
making it meaningless for a good portion
of the year I'm one of them so uh if I
was to tow a trailer and have a plow I
thank you anybody else representative
sellers I didn't know this was going to
be such a thank you Mr chair
as I've heard you say earlier uh
representative Smith say that we're
still handing out two plates if they
want to put on a second plate they can
anybody else I gave representative Sykes
a second bait you can have one too as
representative Sinclair I would just
like to comment that the vast majority
of trailers on the road have a license
plate on them uh up the vast majority
not all of them uh which if somebody's
got a picture of it they can probably
go ahead I would just point out as as I
believe the testimony we heard was that
um
under the current rsas
persons trailer plates are not used to
assign financial
responsibility only plates on the the
anybody else
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll when she's ready the motion is
Vice chairman Gorski no
representative Smith yes the clerk votes
no representative Hill yes
representative Dumas no
representative Melvin
yes
representative Spillane yes
representative C
yes representative sellers
yes representative Sykes
no
sorry no representative Schultz no
representative Sinclair
yes representative Fox
no
representative Rambo
no representative ayo
no representative Coker
yes representative Jones no
representative shuitt no
oh chairman Walsh I'm sorry yes thank
you
thank you
9 to 11. fails fails Mr chairman
okay the motion of oops hold on
motion about the pass fails nine to
eleven uh representative Sykes yes Mr
chairman thank you I may I move
itl I'm really having a hard day I get
up at four this morning so you'll have
to bear with me I'll second that Mr
chair who seconded that representative
hold on
um
take your time
okay so the motion has been moved and
it's been moved and seconded for
octopath thank you representative sakes
now you're getting me confused
um does anybody else wish to speak to
this
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the motion about to pass on
House Bill 388 itl see you've got me
yeah do you think Vice chairman Gorski
yes
representative Smith no
clerk votes yes representative Hill yes
yeah
really
representative Hill is that a yes on the
Ito
sorry motions Ito
no
this is an Ito
the first motion was for ought to pass
it failed 9 11. we've had a subsequent
motion of itl which we need to do to
dispose of the bill so an itl is the
motion
is that yes
do you say yes yes okay thank you
representative Melvin
no
representative Spillane no
representative C
no representative sellers
no representative Sykes yes
representative Schultz yes
representative Sinclair
no
representative Fox
yes representative Rambo yes
representative vayu yes
representative Coker no representative
Jones yes
representative schuett yes
representative style yes and chairman
okay so it's all would be eleven to nine
yep
uh motion of itl is adopted by a big
surprise eleven to nine
uh I'm gonna close the executive session
on House Bill 388.
uh yes that's I guess the thanks for
that this will be our first one going to
the floor with no recommendation do I
have volunteers for
reports on either side of the position
to a Minority Report well they're not
really minority majority whatever it is
actually no these would be this is a
majority did you want to do a Minority
Report
for the help
yeah
anybody interested in doing a majority
report
the
representative representative Vale do it
there's no space here
thanks
okay I'm gonna open up the executive
session on House Bill 393 and that is
permitting a motor vehicle operator to
use only a rear license plate chair
recognizes representative Gorski for a
motion
thank you Mr chair I like to make a
motion to itl
representative I saw representative
Sykes
uh would you care to speak to motion I
would uh thank you Mr chair
um well quite frankly with this this
particular Bill starts getting into the
commercial motor vehicle part of the law
and when that starts getting into that
we're now getting into the the federal
law which
can cause some issues in regards to this
particular Bill and uh quite frankly uh
388 was a simpler Bill we couldn't pass
this one so I'm not sure if this one
would Pass the Mustard either
thank you sir anybody else from the
committee
representative Sinclair
I my problem with this and I didn't
realize is until he had the testimony
was that Vehicles 10 000 pounds to
twenty six thousand pounds uh would be
exempt from that uh having that front
plate and I uh well I guess that was on
the inspection but I I agree that uh
commercial plate Vehicles should have a
front plate for obvious reasons
uh I have to agree with Vice chair
Gorski let's be honest we can save a
bunch of time 388 was the simpler of the
two and it failed uh this one's not
going anywhere
um I'll ask the clerk to call the roll
and she's got a chance
sorry the motion is itl on house bills
393.
Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith
yes
clerk votes yes representative Hill yes
one of them yes
representative Dumas yeah
representative Melvin yes representative
Spillane yes representative C yes
representative sellers yes
representative Sykes yes representative
Schultz yes representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative yes
representative Coker yes representative
Jones yes representative uh schuett yes
representative Stout yes
20s here oh and vice and chairman Walsh
yes
Mr chair okay go ahead could this be
added to the consent well when we get
the count
okay so the motion of Ito is adopted
even though it has a fiscal note can it
still be added correct it's in it's
because it's itl that can
so did you want to move consent okay yes
I would please all right without
objection consent it is
um I'm going to close the executive
session on House Bill 393.
a few minutes to reset we'll be taking
up
okay I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill 597 FN relative to
racing ethnicity data on driver's
licenses and race and ethnicity data
collection Jay recognizes representative
sellers for a motion
and give us the chair I motion to itl
this bill
seconded by representative Smith
uh would you care to speak to motion
yes I would thank you
so so this bill I was looking at it here
um
excuse me I just lost it in my apologies
I might even just close the whole tab
but anyways I believe it's uh it's under
RSA 260 14a that it's changing and
adding to and it's it's collecting
statistical data but the data that it's
collecting is not all inclusive because
you the driver has uh whoever's applying
for the license has the option of
of providing that option material of
ethnicity and also race so therefore
your data automatically is going to be
skewed it won't have all the data that
should have it will only have a partial
data set and therefore trying to
really get good statistics out of it
you're just not going to get it
thank you sir anybody else from the
committee
representative Sinclair I hear what
you're saying are representative but the
testimony we had from Public Safety
officials amongst others was that this
was they agreed about that but this was
a start and at this point any uh
information is better than no
information
that's what I took from it
so
during testimony for this bill I think
it was there was broad support for
passage of it and I just would tell a
personal story that the first time I
heard about this not this specific bill
but the the concept of collecting
racial and ethnic data
through whatever means my immediate
reaction was no we don't want to do that
but then when we heard testimony and it
was further explained to me why this is
an important
thing to do
um
I changed my mind
it was a good thing to do and we heard
from a variety of different
organizations we heard from the all of
whom were in support of this bill we
heard from the ACLU the police Chiefs
specifically police chief from Hollis
and also retired police chief from Dover
we heard from the NAACP we heard from
the New Hampshire Department of Justice
we heard from the New Hampshire State
Police
they all make the point they all made
the essential point that this will be a
police response and that the current
Tools in our Tool Shed are inadequate
I'll use as an example
my community the city of Lebanon is one
of the few departments in the state that
is Coleus certified
but in speaking to my police chief about
this bill and what the efforts that they
make to collect racial and ethnic data
he acknowledged that it was an
incomplete tool in the Khalia toolbox
and that it would be
and so if it's an incomplete tool and we
have a way to add further data
and again we should be making database
decisions
if we don't have any data now how can it
be a bad thing to get additional data
and so that's why I'm fully in support
of this having changed my mind about how
it might work because
the the things that will happen would be
it could do it could go both ways
this data once collected could show that
a police department
is doing a great job their ethnic
population may be two percent
and they have
two percent stops
for that ethnic group
great sounds like they're doing a re a
really good job of of
bare unbiased police work
community-based police work which is
really important
however it could also be that the ethnic
population in my city for instance is
what if we were stopping 25 percent
of this what if 25 of the stops were
people from an ethnic with a different
ethnicity than the remainder
that says
my police chief I know what he would do
he'd say I've got to work on this we've
got to do better
how do you get that tool if you don't
start collecting the data I urge my
colleagues on the transportation
committee to allow the collection of
data that will improve policing in
general improve community policing
specifically and would help those
departments that are on the road to
improving and doing a better job for the
anybody else in the committee
representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman I'm having a hard
time determining or or understanding how
you would be able to determine that 11
of your stops
were in one category when you don't have
the complete set of data to show what 11
consists of
it wouldn't you can't
you can't always blanket say that some
data is better than no data in this case
it's not if you have inaccurate or
incomplete data then you're painting an
incorrect
picture when you try to
assess that data that's that's why I
will be
anybody else in the committee
representative of you
one of our biggest complaints on the
committee is the lack of data we've
actually killed a bill today because we
didn't have any data that supported it
this bill seems to start the process of
collecting data it's not perfect because
opt-in data is not going to be perfect
but right now the the only data we have
is data that's reported by the police
and we've already had a testimony that
said that sometimes they're misreporting
and we don't know why
so if that's a trend if if there's
habitual misreporting of race or
perceived race in a stop we can't
compare that to any other information
because we don't have it so this bill
just simply starts the process of
collecting the data and how it's used in
the future will be up to each individual
individual Department as they report to
the state and of course it's going to be
the people who know how to use the data
are going to understand that it's not
further comments from the committee I'll
go back and forth representative Gorski
thank you Mr chair well my concern with
the bill is you know we had the police
Chiefs here and especially the police
chief of Hollis and you know one of the
questions that I asked was how often
would you look at this data and he said
yearly
now if this data is so important why are
we only looking at it for one year if
we're going to have this data I would
think you want to look at it on a
consistent basis so it doesn't seem like
there is a consistent process here in
terms of analyzing the data and that's
the kind of the issue I have with the
bill
representative Rumbo
um we are a testimony on this bill or
during the hearing that
um it puts officers in a difficult
position that they shouldn't need to be
inquiring of individuals that they
stopped about their race or ethnicity
um and but that they may need to
identify that information in their
reports and that there's not always
accurate information recorded
not necessarily knowing why but to the
extent that we may not all be able to
make that assessment
in an interaction with an individual
accurately assess their race or
ethnicity I think this is a tool that
also provides our officers more
information for when they're filling out
the report so that they are not having
to make a judgment call on their own
whether that's on the idea whether it's
listed as a code asks rather in artfully
during the hearing but it would be a
code or if it would be listed by you
know color ethnicity
um I think this is a tool not only for
data but also for law enforcement to for
anybody else representative Smith
thank you Mr chair
um so my view of this is based on my
four years as a database quality analyst
for a tech company the only thing this
actually gives you the only data it
provides is the total number of people
of a given race or ethnicity who are
willing to self-report it's not even a
percentage because we don't have
accurate numbers on what the total
potential pool is
my fear is that if anybody if we did
this and anybody looked at it they might
make a decision based on it and that
would be dangerous let's say
hypothetically that African Americans
are twice as likely to self-report as
Hispanics when you're talking to low
numbers that we have in this state that
could easily show it's completely
incorrect result when you look at the
totals
so what action would they take based on
that if it's just
all
non-white races or ethnicities in
general you don't need this level of
granularity because the state is
literally not going to prove anything
and potentially produce a flawed result
now the part that really winds my crack
though is ethnicity it isn't defined I
don't know what it means here's an
example my mother
her parents were born in Cuba and
Germany
what box does she check what's her
ethnicity is it which culture she feels
and which doesn't particularly feel like
either one and she's just herself
I don't know what ethnicity proves I
couldn't possibly support the bill with
such a subjective term in it if you're
looking for data-driven results I don't
think there is one for this I am
Cuban German Norwegian and Austrian what
am I besides a fascist to enjoys skiing
and my whole family hasn't won a war in
100 years I mean I don't know of what
value that is to anybody
I know someone who their parents are
Chinese and Indian which boxes do they
check and how uncomfortable is the
conversation that you have to have to
explain it I don't want any part of it
this doesn't produce any data that can
be actually used for anything it makes
people feel awkward and I can't support
it
any representative Sykes
so a couple of things that I forgot to
mention one a lot of data is available
partly it's called the U.S census and
they break down ethnicity
into a bunch of different things and so
we have beginning points I didn't pull
11 of the population of my city
from thin air because I could I got it
we do not want to make subjective
choices about our ethnicity and in fact
because it is an opt-in program and it
gives the person the opportunity to
decide for themselves
what they are it might help solve
representative Smith's problem about
okay
um I'm actually surprised that we're
debating this to this point I thought
this was a much simpler Bill I'm glad
you did bring up the U.S census because
when it asks for ethnicity it's also
optional it's optional because it's
against federal law to require that
information that's why it's also an
option in if House Bill 597 and and I
agree with the people supporting this
motion I've been here for 10 years and I
cannot tell you how many times I have
heard in committee rooms show me the
data show me the data show me the data
well in this case we're going to have
incomplete data with it being optional
it's as simple as that you cannot call
it reliable I don't know what purpose it
serves and I will also be supporting the
itl
representative Schmidt Schultz but
that's okay Schultz sorry you know we
are all German in that sense
um we being Schmitz and Schultz's anyway
um I haven't
never needed to mention this in any
committee before so I hope it's of some
value but
um as someone who
uh has multiple graduate level
statistics statistics classes in
criminology
I can say
it is often true that the data is
incomplete and yet it is sufficient
enough
to make decisions that saves money
improves laws
um helps police officers helps people
who train police officers and that's
what we're looking at
um I think I hope these are all really
the reasons why people feel the way they
do about this bill I think regardless of
what the data shows it will be helpful
I'm sure our police officers are
fantastic and we should be able to help
equip police officers and those who
train police officers
with the knowledge of how things
actually are panning out
that's all this is
allows people to make decisions based on
it it's really not more complicated than
that
thank you I will reiterate I think no
data is better than incorrect or
incomplete data I'm going to ask the
foreign
Gorski yes
representative Smith yes the clerk votes
yes representative Hill yes
representative Dumas yes representative
Melvin
yes representative Spillane yes
representative C
yes representative sellers yes
representative Sykes
no representative Schultz new
representative Sinclair
no
representative Fox no representative
Rambo no Representative theyo no
representative Koger no representative
Jones no representative uh schulert no
it excuse me and representative stubb uh
no like yeah no no
good time no yeah
okay
what was your answer was it now and uh
chairman uh Walsh
uh this is an ideal yes
representative Sykes is recognized I
assume for a motion yes thank you Mr
chairman I make a motion of ought to
pass
motion about the past second
at that representative Jones seconded by
representative Jones any further
discussion on this representative Sykes
uh thank you Mr chairman I I believe
we've heard all the arguments that we
need to do and even you and I might be
I'm going to leave that alone
um
and with no other further discussion
I'll ask the clerk to call the role the
motion is ought to pass on House Bill
597.
oops
representative Smith no
clerk votes no representative Hill no
representative Dumas no
representative Melvin
no
representative Spillane no
representative C
no representative sellers no
representative Sykes
yes representative Schultz yes
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox
yes representative Rambo yes
representative
yes yes representative Coker yes
representative Jones yes representative
uh shulit yes
representative stubb yes
chairman Walsh
10 to 10. okay so the motion of ought to
pass fails 10 10.
uh with no amendments I think it's
simple enough looks like this will be
moving to the floor without
recommendation
so um do we have any volunteers for
positions
we'll sort that out afterwards I'm going
to close the executive session on House
okay I'm gonna open up the executive
session on House Bill 646 eliminating
the vehicle inspection mandate for
non-commercial Vehicles Jay recognizes
representative Crawford for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I make a motion of
itl on House Bill 646 FN
seconded by representative Sykes
representative Crawford would you care
to speak to your motion
yes Mr chairman besides the idea um
basically that it's unsafe for vehicles
to be on the road that aren't inspected
uh annually the
um I'm
kind of astounded by the revenue loss
for the state about 4 million 225
000 and
um the revenue lost to local
um municipalities of about five hundred
and seven thousand dollars so uh put
those all together I feel an Ito isn't
order
anybody else from the committee
first of all Mr chair I wish we weren't
voting on this today since we just heard
it today it's the one we just heard
today correct
I I would have liked to have a week to
check on some of these figures
especially uh the the financial thing
about cities losing money on this
because in all my life going to City
Council meetings and and listening to
budget reports I have never once heard
the City of Laconia refer to money taken
in by inspections it's always been
registrations
not inspections and I'm just not sure
where that's coming from and now I'm not
going to have the chance to figure that
one out so
um I and I know the comment was just
made about the safety of uh our highways
but again we have so many vehicles that
come into this state year round from
states that don't require it and I've
here we go with the information or data
I've never seen any information that
we've had all these accidents in this
state caused by vehicles that come from
states with no inspection uh required
and I'm not talking about air emissions
I'm talking about inspections thank you
anybody else from the committee
represent sellers thank you Mr chair
you know when it comes to inspections we
know in essence they're absolutely good
but they're only good for that one
moment in time as soon as you
drive off the out the door of the garage
it's you know it's something could
happen
but the other problem is I have is that
we're not allowing people to have and
take their own responsibility and this
is a responsibility of the person that
owns the vehicle and I think that as
New Hampshire citizens we should have
the freedom to have our personal
responsibility and be able to say our
car is safe or not or to drive it or not
with or without an inspection sticker
no
well with nobody else I'll mention a
couple of things
um in terms of looking into anything on
the fiscal note this bill was introduced
in transportation six weeks ago I'm
waiting for the hearing just to answer
questions like data in print isn't
necessary
um the other thing I've seen in my 10
years I cannot tell you how many bills
to eliminate the inspection program
unfortunately some things have not
changed the fiscal note hasn't changed
that's always been an issue violating
the Gordon Derby contract and that
financial burden will be an issue
um what else did I have jotted down
potential Highway funds that are at risk
uh if we get rid of this uh at this time
uh but this bill in particular
because it has an overlay but the
commercial driver's licenses and that's
the major change that starts all this it
can be done a lot of different ways this
one to me makes it a uh exceptionally
more difficult to uh to look at only
because now when we start going into
Motor Carrier laws that are governed by
the federal government we're going down
a slippery slope for all those Reasons
um without with the I'm sorry doesn't it
say here it's me I I'm sorry I thought
you agree I just you know what I mean no
fairness I did look at you go ahead
represent Sinclair
doesn't it say for non-commercial
Vehicles right there in the bill an act
eliminating the vehicle inspection
but there are a lot of commercial
vehicles from 10 000 to 26 000 pounds
that you don't need a commercial license
for that are treated commercially those
do fall underneath federal law you need
you don't need a commercial license for
it but because of the gross vehicle
weight of those they are governed you
need a medical card if they're being
used commercially
it's all part of the um
I'm just drawing a blame but they do
have Federal overlays as we just heard
in the testimony today
that that's what makes it challenging
for me on this one I've seen different
attempts that didn't bring in the
yeah go ahead I I agree with you on this
Mr chair and my question would be it and
if this if it's probably too late now
again because we're voting on this now
but had this committed with an amendment
to change that part of it to eliminate
that 10 000 and above from being exempt
from an inspection is that are you
saying that that's something you would
have supported I'm not I don't know if I
would have supported or not but that's
the reason I don't think this bill will
work I didn't know that I did somebody
mention there was an amendment floating
on but I did not see it
um if we think we want to see the
amendment at this point with the motion
that's on the floor unfortunately we're
going to have to defeat this motion uh
to go any further is there an amendment
so I I did have an amendment drafted up
um for uh you know my thought was making
it biannual and um I did kind of in the
financial note it talked about the
commercial vehicles over ten thousand
pounds so basically my Amendment would
kind of fix that so that those Vehicles
would still be covered under the
inspections
um so the the what I'm kind of hearing
is that you know where the admissions
part is kind of the sticking point for
the one year so I'd like more I mean I I
don't know if there's a way we could
retain this or maybe more time to look
at this
um I'm not a huge you know I don't want
to get rid of inspections altogether but
I
you know I would like to look into this
a little bit more but
I don't know how that works
fair enough but unfortunately the way it
works were we we do have a motion on the
floor that has been second and so if the
committee believes that we either want
to make another motion to retain or
other then we'll have to defeat the one
that's here
um that's just that's where we're at and
so anybody else wish to speak on the itl
okay I don't see anybody else to speak
to the Ito with that being said I'll ask
the clerk to call the roll uh as soon as
she's ready Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith no
clerk votes yes representative Hill no
representative Melvin
yes
representative Spillane no
representative C
no representative sellers
no representative Sykes
yes representative Schultz yes
representative Sinclair no
yes representative Rambo yes
representative yes representative Coker
no representative Jones yes
representative shulit yes
yes
12 to
12 to 8.
motion to itl is adopted 12 to 8 or our
recommendation is adopted 12 to 8. I'm
going to close the executive session on
a few minutes to regroup we're gonna
okay welcome back everybody I'm going to
open up the executive session on House
a chair recognizes representative gorsky
for a motion thank you Mr chair I'd like
to make a motion to retain house bill
650. motions to retain is there a second
representative seconds care to speak to
you motion I do thank you Mr chairman
um from listening to the testimony there
seems to be some Merit in this and looks
like there's still some things that can
be worked out on this bill
um I think our friends potentially in
judiciary might be able to help us a
little bit here so I think it might be a
good idea to retain it to see if we can
uh tighten this up a little bit
thank you sir anybody else in the
committee
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll the motion is retain on House
Bill 650.
Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
Dumas yes representative Melvin yes
representative Spillane yes
representative C yes representative
sellers yes representative Sykes
yes representative Schultz yes
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative yes
representative Coker
yes
representative Jones yes
representative shulet
yes representative Stout yes
20-0
yes
okay it was uh voted 20-0 to retain
House Bill 650 we don't need reports on
that
um but we do need reports on
House Bill 260 388
393 597 and 646. again you've got them
on your laptops if you if you
if you have them here hopefully if you
don't I can't get you hard copies if you
want to do it the old school way but I
really do need them before you leave I
will be here to help anybody that's
never done a report that has any
questions I know it's uh
Deputy speaker Smith has also
volunteered to hang around for a few if
anybody's got any questions doing the
reports
um so
I guess that's all I read for today
um we will be scheduling again for next
Tuesday
um we are going to bring up 374 and 375
next week I can't put them off any
longer because they aren't really bills
I haven't decided what how to fill the
rest of the day yet so stay tuned for
the calendar
report
five minutes
you're only doing five nine
um
yeah
even though my electric bill last month
foreign